- What is your favorite Disney movie?
Well it's not here.
Beauty and the Beast.
No...this...
(crowd laughing)
is bullshit.
This doesn't work.
(upbeat music)
- My favorite Disney movie
is The Little Mermaid.
It came out when I was nine years old.
A crab started singing
a Caribbean calypso tune
and my life was never the same.
- My favorite Disney character/princess/
kickbutt heroine was Mulan.
From a young age she
totally broke a gender norm
and I thought that was so cool.
- My favorite Disney princess
is um...Cinderella.
- [Man] What do you
look for in a soulmate?
- I like adventure.
I'm also very, like, happy
and I don't like making plans
so you need to be adventurous
if you wanna hang with me.
- I look for...humor.
- I'm going to go with kindness.
Everything else fades.
- [Dwayne] Secretly,
you think your enemies
are envious of...?
- I'm gonna say
my passions.
- My industriousness.
You can call me a lot of things
but lazy is none of them.
- I don't have enemies.
- [Man] What is happily ever after?
- I am going to press
the adventure continues.
- I mean I've seen Into the Woods,
there's no such thing
as happily ever after.
Life just keeps going.
There's no act two, there's no act three.
You just keep evolving.
Oh, there's one for that,
the adventure continues.
I'll click that.
- The adventure continues.
- You got Ariel.
Girl, Under the Sea, let's go.
- I got Ariel (claps), Brah!
I knew I was gonna get Ariel.
You are a dreamer who's always thinking
of the next big step in your life.
Some may think you have
set your sights too high,
but your friends know you
are capable of anything.
- Wow, I got Jasmine.
Daring and adventurous, you
are considered the daredevil
for your group.
You enjoy having fun, taking risks,
and living life to the fullest.
You also are incredibly
handsome and you smell good.
Nice.
Here's the thing, I was
looking at these princesses
and then I thought, you know what,
I just, I gotta pick Jasmine
at the top of this thing,
but then I thought wait, that's too cheesy
because I'd be a doting dad
because my daughter's name is Jasmine,
so I'm not gonna do it.
And then (snaps), as
such the universe works,
I wound up being Jasmine,
so I'm very happy about that.
(laughing)
I love BuzzFeed, man.
- [Women] We love you.
- You guys are the best.
Really, you guys are the best,
I always take your quizzes.